You could, you could be like this, you know,
like we just had a show about blessing. You know, I spend the holiday times.
I've been thinking about that. Nope,
it's true. Actually, you know, it's been snowing.
It W I was in St Louis just a couple of days ago and it was snowing,
these big fat,
fluffy flakes and I couldn't help but think some of those flakes must be
perfectly shaped crystalline structures right out of cave except there wouldn't
snow in his case. I don't know.
I don't understand this yearning for the perfect when you've got real pretty
great snowflakes falling right on your nose. Like why don't you hold on,
let's just start it up. I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich, Radiolab,
the podcast and today we're going to continue the conversation we were just
having, we've been having all week about, uh, well perfection, you know,
like striving for things which seem perfect versus living in the real world.
And uh, recently I got into a bit of a kerfuffle with a guy who,
who yearns like you do for an id. This,
his name is Jim Hall, and he wrote this really good book called,
why does the World Exist?
And just to get us started in that book, he quotes a poem. Yeah.
Remember the line? Ah, yeah. Kick kick at the rock. Sam Johnson.
Break your bones. But cloudy. Cloudy is the stuff of stones cloudy.
Cloudy is the stuff of stone. Meaning what? It's something. Well, uh, uh,
uh, Samuel Johnson, who lived in the 18th century, uh,
it was a contemporary of Bishop Barclay and Bishop Barclay was an idealist.
He believed that the world was essentially pure appearance.
It was like a thought, not like a solid reality.
It was a thought in the mind of God.
Like the rock really had no substance. And Samuel Johnson, when he heard this,
he thought it was ridiculous and he went and kicked a stone and said,
I refute Barclay. Thus, um, anyway, that's the story.
Wait, willing. I thought it was a thought. The other guy thought the rock was a,
what are they arguing about exactly where all they're arguing about reality?
Just what is the, this world, what is its, you know, essential. Uh, uh, nature.
When you hold a rock in your hand, like what's it made of? What's it made of?
Yeah. Uh, minerals. No,
is that the asking is what is the most essential nature of the rock?
So if you look deep, deep, deep down into the Rock,
do you find something concrete?
Do you find a little bit of thing or where do you find something more if
furious? Something you can't touch, something you can't pin down something like,
oh, a thought. This is Jim's notes.
Now this sounds like a, it sounds like I'd been eating Lotus sleeves too,
but I mean it's, it's a pipe dream,
but this is what science has increasingly led us to
that rocks or thoughts? Well, to follow Jim's logic,
he goes all the way back to the Greeks to the first real attempt to get to
what's really at the bottom of Iraq.
You know, even in ancient times,
the atomised Democritus and loose IPUs thought that if you keep cutting up the
stuff of reality that we see around us, tables, chairs and rocks and so forth,
eventually you,
you cut them up into such itty bitty pieces that you can't cut any further.
And then you've got Adam's. So there you've got,
you've clearly got a fundamental stuff, the Adams study, are you pleased?
But I'm even going back to Newton.
There were reasons to suspect that there was something a little funny about
reality. It wasn't quite as substantial as we believed.
Okay?
No. Newton of course, came up with a theory of gravity.
And the theory of gravity says, if you've got the sun and a planet,
the sun exerts a gravitational force on the planet. Okay.
And Newton's contemporaries wanted to know, well, how does it do that?
What is the mechanism that by which gravity is mediated, how does the sun,
as it were recharged to the earth and,
and force it to move around to this orbit?
So if I were an Atha mist, if I were looking for stuff,
then I'd need some kind of thing that carried gravity. Yeah. Yeah.
But the problem is it looks like there's nothing between the earth and the sun
except a void.
All the Newton had to fill that void was a mathematical equation that told them
how the sun and the earth interact. And the thing is, it worked.
You could plug in the numbers and you could know how one was influencing the
other, but Newton had no idea at all why the equation work.
He couldn't point to any like a little particle thing, like a graviton as it.
There's your reason.
It almost seemed like gravity was created from the equation itself and this
disturbed a lot of people because at that time everybody thought that nature has
to meet, be made out of hard, durable stuff, you know, years,
sprockets, pushing and pulling. That's the essence of reality.
Then in the 20th century, of course it got much, much worse. You know, the,
the Adam, which was thought to be very,
very tiny and you couldn't cut it any further. It was the limit to this,
you know, splitting process. Right.
And as we know all too well from the 20th century, you can split it at and yeah,
it has pretty interesting consequences.
But we also discovered the Adam is almost entirely empty space, Huh?
It's,
it's if you took a baseball and put it in the middle of Madison Square Garden,
that would be like the nucleus and the the, you know,
the first level of electrons or as far away as the exterior of the garden.
So you can think of this baseball, this nucleus as a tiny God all alone.
So it's basically the Adam is a big empty space. Well it doesn't feel that way.
Like watch this, I'm going to do this.
If my hands are all Adams and as you say, atoms are mostly empty space,
then why don't my hands just go right to each other like two clouds.
But you'll notice. Yeah, why don't I fall through the floor here?
Because the floor is mostly empty space and I'm mostly empty space. That too.
If you look at it in the micro level, this appearance,
solidity is the product of a purely mathematical,
isn't it more like my electrons don't like similar electron.
So the electrons in my hands just hate the electrons. On the other hand,
it basically comes down to a pair of mathematical relations that the,
the Paoli exclusion principle and the Heisenberg uncertainty principle.
I mean all of this, this gets very abstract, right?
I understand it perfectly of questions.
I don't want to bore you with the details of his,
like you have no idea what he's saying. Well,
I'll say this according to Jim,
it's not that the electrons in my left hand are repelling the electrons in my
right hand. It has to do with a law of nature. The says two particles,
identical particles can not be in the same place at the same time.
So when you hear that sound,
you can hear it as the sound of a law saying no, not allowed.
Not In nature. Exactly. And here's, here's a, a, um,
so slightly different way of putting that, but wait,
isn't this law that we are announcing? Isn't this law about, uh,
particles like we're talking about atoms and electrons. Those are things.
So we're still, we're still talking about things. Well, uh, if you,
if you study quantum field theory,
which is what all physics graduate students at begin with in graduate school,
you discover the, even particles are unreal.
They're just temporary properties of what are called fields and fields are just
distributions of mathematical quantities through space time.
So they're not, they don't seem to be grounded in anything.
According to Jim, a field is kinda like a stream of numbers,
pure information numbers that tell you where a particle,
like an electron might be.
So maybe the blood trends over here or maybe it's over there or maybe it's with
dispute. Maybe it's with Vac.
The problem is you can't ever see the thing itself. You can only see it
the effect it has on other things.
So you can't observe it.
And if something is in principle unobservable you may as well say it doesn't
exist.
Wait a second. No, I know what I mean. I'm on his side.
But you could say that it's just not observable down there.
At the microscale up here. It's pretty observable. I mean, this table exists,
this mixer, I mean, something is happening to give the world substance will,
according to Jim, we think happens in this,
I admittedly is eight in a gross over simplification.
But in these fields you're going to get these little fluctuations,
these little events, certain hiccups of energy, cool bursts,
and that's where stuffiness flickers into existence.
But it's a very flickering existence. Stuff isn't permanent.
So what is a rock? I mean a rock looks like a good solid persisting object,
but it's really our perception of it is energy transitions,
changes in the distribution of energy from one state to another.
When that happens, the energy is irradiated. It goes through my retina,
[inaudible] pupil rather and strikes my retina and I perceive the rock.
So going back to that poem we started with,
I dunno if Jim would call a rock like Bishop Barclay did a thought in the mind
of God.
But you might say that deep down what a rock is is an expression of rules or
math. It's just here like a shadow of an idea. Yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
I've heard one physicists say that the cosmos is ultimately a concept.
No.
Are you increasingly convinced that the reason you can clap,
the reason you don't fall through the floor?
The reason that gravity works is all because of certain ideas that govern ideas.
Rule the world. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe, you know,
at a hundred years from now when a string theory is finally worked out,
we might have a very different conception of it, but it would,
it looks as though it's going to be mathematics and structure all the way down.
You're okay with this? Well, I'm a sort of mathematical romantic.
I love the idea that the essence of reality is not stuff.
You know who the stuff is kind of ugly and you want to get rid of stuff.
There's too much stuff in your apartment flutter. It's
[inaudible]. I don't have style that, you know,
this is the temperamental difference between us.
I like the idea that reality consists, it's a,
it's a flux of pure information with no further substance.
I don't know why this makes you so happy. I mean here I,
I would love if I clapping or if I'm hitting someone in the face.
I would love to think the billiard ball of me is hitting the billiard ball of
them. And that explains what's going on.
Now you've offered living in an almost in a spiritual realm.
You want to live in this, in this gross material realm.
And where there's a lot of turns out we're, we're chewable realm.
It's literally empty. It's like,
it's it so intuitively wrong that if you go back to the old, you know,
19th century view that we're made up of these little hard particle Adams that
are all bumping around.
Is it any more plausible that you and I are just a bunch of dumb hard particles
in a certain configuration? And if that's true, you know how,
how are certain configurations of these particles Tan them out to the horrible
feeling of pain?
You could say pain all that's just a lot of elementary particles in a certain
configuration, but we all know that explanation isn't enough.
So when you look down to the bottom of everything,
whether it's a mathematical object or whether it's little billiard balls
knocking around there, it's still
vernaculars and [inaudible] it probable that it should produce subjective
experience that it should produce, you know,
pleasure and pain and that mystery,
how you go from the most basic things are actually the most basic nothings to
everything we see around us. I find that to be exhilarating,
to worry about that, you know,
the metaphysics of physics and the nature of reality,
even though it doesn't lead you to any sort of comfortable intellectual closure,
um, it makes for,
it's a good way of idling away and otherwise boring afternoon is we've just
proved. It also explains why when I hid better to him with my,
with my very strong for him, he seemed to think of it as a fascinating thought.
Now let's stop it.
Special thanks to Jim Holt,
who actually we were both too shy to ever head but each other in two weeks to
try it anyway. He's, he has a wonder. The book is called,
why does the World Exist? An existential detective story.
Okay. Well, I guess that's it for this podcast. A happy new year. Everybody.
I'm Chad Apple. I'm Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.